so it's the end of a very long day
and I know I've said this many times
before but this really is the bit that
we've been waiting for any minute now
the landing window will open that means
between now and about half an hour's
time filet will be landing on the comet
but what kind of landing it is
completely depends on how lucky filet is
might land on a boulder on a cliff on a
ridge this spot was selected as being
the best possible place to land on the
comet but still is littered with hazards
now we just have to cross our fingers
and wait
while we've been waiting we've seen some
amazing images the first one was all
Rosetta that was taken by VA as it said
farewell when it went miss to send down
to the comments the second one which I
can give even more amazing was taken
from the acai rest instrument on Rosetta
and it was of the lander as it went on
its descent if you can see it just in
the distance but really really clearly
with this legs out it looks almost like
a little skull and crossbones to me so
we've now got these amazing images but
all they do is make us even more want to
see the final pictures that we might get
if the night ends on landing safely in
the service
my question is very simple how are you
feeling right now today I feel so happy
and so relieved also because we we know
the difficulties of this type of mission
and
success looks always easy but it was not
easy but we made it and we we are the
first who have made that and that will
stay forever so we have landed on a
comment and and I am sure that the
scientists will learn a lot about the
solar system a lot of planet Earth and
maybe a lot about us and that is but
that will come the the work of the
engineers is almost now like complete
now this is the scientist starting to to
work and I am sure that there will be a
lot of discoveries it was real cool
it was worth the effort and world the
fears and the stress special special
liberation of my party and all my
brightening okay it is a great event
non president event it is who you first
and similarly in the way then in the
history of human civilization so we've
had touchdown the landings been
confirmed it's probably a bit cheesy to
say so but I think it's probably been
the most exciting day of reporting in my
life um everything seems to be going
pretty well there have been a few
hiccups the harpoons didn't actually go
into the surface and we don't know what
that will mean it perhaps means that
fillet is a little bit vulnerable down
there on the comet but I think for now
we can safely say they have landed
you